almost everyone I know wants to one day
be successful however there's a very big
difference between attaining success and
sustaining success let me say one more
time attaining sustaining attaining is
one time sustaining is a long time the
world history books media news TV is
filled with stories of people who went
up like this and add a major fall you
know why because they did something here
that is the formula for fall coming
right around the corner
let me explain to what that is I'm
talking to from pure experience when
they get up here this is what takes
place everybody around you wants to
start telling you how amazing you are
and oh my gosh you're so amazing I can't
believe how amazing you are
dude you the greatest you're better than
this person that better oh my gosh all
this stuff all this stuff that gets feed
into your mind and if you're not too
careful you start believing it and when
you start believing it you experience
this this Idol that's godlike figure
that maybe I am bigger than life and
you're not nobody
everyone dies you're not immortal I'm
not immortal we're all mortal mortal
means you're going to die even Elon Musk
is going to die no matter how much
people idolize what is the point here
look the first time this happened to me
and I had a major fall I was 23 years
old the best thing that ever happened to
me but this is what I learned this is
what I learned I learned there's only a
handful of people compliment and
criticism that matters too it's my
mentors and it's my immediate family
when they say things to me it matters to
me compliment and criticism so if they
sit me down and they say hey you're not
doing this right I mean I'm in town
riding on LA visiting family we had a
good time Europe had a lot of good
dinners my friends my mentors different
people
does not have in conversations together
and when there's a direct talk you would
try to like it when there's a compliment
you internalize it a compliment from the
five people that matter the most to me
is a million times more important than 1
million comments saying how amazing I am
and I tell you why I'm sharing this with
you because my simple outcome with you
is not only for you to attain success
one time tell us you not only attain
success but sustain success for such a
long time and the way you do that is by
taking the attention off of you less
about you and make it more about the
people you're serving the way you fight
this temptation which all of us are
going to face no one is perfect like
there is not this perfect person all
good I'll never because I'm such a holy
person I go to church every Sunday no no
no no there's no such thing we all could
fall with it but the way you do it is
take the attention off you put it on the
attention around the people that are on
your team the people that you're serving
the Kleins
all that stuff that are working with you
and all of us thing you start noticing
what does he gets in my head anymore I'm
good I'm humbled I have good
relationships I've good friendship but
man when those people tell me things
that I need to improve on dad's really
matter Pilate and I think once you do
that and I'm you got to work your butt
off you got to do all this other stuff
and you start at any successful and
telling you keep redeveloping you're
supporting it on other other people not
only will you keep sustaining good man
you can have a lot of strong
relationships for the rest of your life
at the end of the day I mean you want to
drive nice cars to go out with other
people a nice cars you want to travel
the world because you want to go travel
the world with people that you enjoyed
their relationship and their association
who wants to do it alone no one wants to
do it so hopefully we can not only see
this now if you already attaining
success on how to make the adjustments
but if you haven't yet when it does
happen
keep this in the back your mind just
store it somewhere here so when it
happens you sustain a problem